all right tyrone
tyrone where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from chicago
illinois
chicago and uh tell me about your family
you had both your parents when you were
a
kid
well i was with my parents but
pops were never around he was alcoholic
workaholic moms was just kind of quiet
you know what i'm saying quiet and just
seemed like she was lost
because i was lost uh they used to
always take me over grandma's house
um i actually go to grandma's house when
i was a kid
five six years old and i stayed with
grandma all the time we had no tv in our
house
you know what i'm saying this man used
to always come over there
see my mother is my father second wife
she went with my father
when i got old when i was sick of the
birth ticket daddy was like
45 momma was 21. so daddy had kids
before
from his first wife so that's going to
end up in my story because you know i'm
going to tell you the boogeyman really
exists
now this man was over grandma's house
this guy used to always go in and beat
grandma up
grandma used to always had black eyes
then i used to try to say grandma
and he used to beat me up and throw me
in the next room
and he did whatever he did with grandma
i just hit her screaming
but then he would come over there with
me and do things to me
and this went on for a long for a while
now five
six seven eight nine ten years old
and nobody never said nothing i want to
know
did daddy know mama wasn't going to say
that mama's quiet anyway
but i wonder you know
that daddy ever know me because daddy is
he was always going to get me from
grandma i just go over
every day
but you would take me back every day
because daddy had worked and mama did
whatever she did at home
if she stayed home
and and the things he was kept doing
these things to me
and i kind of seemed like it was kind of
normal
i was kind of you know like like i can
like looking forward to things like that
sexual things
sexual things you know and but see i was
a kid i didn't know
started at five years old it was five
years old
and it's like following me
playing doing things and it's time
like that i wanted that type of
attention
from a man and i'm not saying i'm gonna
i just wanted that attention you know
when i was a kid just seemed like it was
the thing to do
to have a strong head around me or
touching me and i didn't know and i
would always wonder and as time went by
this man kept showing up
you know what i'm saying i was getting
uh and he was coming over to the house
and i was like you know what i'm saying
and he would stay over the house i go
what's this this man
you know every that was all but nobody
said nothing
i never said nothing because i was too
scared to say something
but i enjoyed him being around
you know i was and he would eat
you know he would stay over but he would
come in my room
you know what i'm saying like late night
you know
sometimes i come in the room people
sitting at my you know
playing with my games they tell me to
come over
at in my room and i sit right next to
him
it seemed like nobody didn't know
nothing nobody didn't care
i don't know i was a kid
but i think i believed at that time
everything was all right
it was the thing to do you know
and you know how they say the boogie man
it was under your bed and in the closet
when you was a kid that's all we had was
the boogie man
to be scared of you know what i'm saying
so when i'm coming in room as time i
kept coming in the room
so as that the lights kept lights was
always off
but it was only a little corner we're
lighting it with my game
and when i come in i just go straight
over there
yeah he was if he went at work he was
drunk
somewhere the day was working hard
workaholic alcoholic and mama didn't say
nothing anyway so
you know back in the day a woman stayed
in her place
you know you guys don't say nothing a
man pay the cost to be the boss
that's how i when i grew up your kids
is not to say a word seen but not spoken
and that's how i was you know as time
went by it's just
whatever happened it was supposed to be
normal but was i normal was i have no
more was i insane without you know
saying i don't know i was so confused
and this man just kept on being around
you know what i'm saying and he was
about as old as mama
you know what i'm saying i'm gonna tell
you that's gonna keep going he was
oldest mama and nobody said nothing to
him
because he was always around i'm like
you know but every day
when daddy did go to work they would
take me to grandma's house
and he ended up coming over to grandma's
house
grandma even knew him and we'll let him
in
like man what's what's wrong what's
happening man
you know i'm just confused about this
man because everybody
seems like it's all right with him so
i'm trying to be all right with him
but the things he's doing to me
i guess it's all right because ain't
nobody else said nothing
ain't nobody said a word so
he would sit at the table he would eat
he would do everything like
he was like he was part of the family
and as time went by he was part of the
family
he was my my half brother for my
father's
first wife
and i never knew this he like i said he
was just as old as my mama
my pops left his first wife ended up
meeting my mama
like i said he was about 45 so my mom
was 21.
so when i looked at my birth period when
i was a kid growing up
i said that i saw a big difference it
was
and his time went by and when i got
older i'm like
and i found out that was his first his
his first son he's a junior
because i want to realize why i wasn't a
junior
i wanted to be like my daddy
i wanted to be a workaholic my pops rest
in peace
stayed on his job for 47 years same job
i could never do that
i could never do that i want to be just
like him
but my probably start with the boy you
actually need it
my dad was strong
[Music]
and i had nobody look up to
but this man who always gave me some
attention
and grabber grandma was strong
my mother did the message to him
she did the best security and you know
what
when i was raised family
and friends is very important to have
life
i'm
they mean something
you know they help you they don't use
you
you can go to anything you want to go to
nobody never look at you wrong they're
always trying to help you
they always feed you
always family
family is very important to have man and
friends
that you grew up with from a kid on
his family you call his mama mama
that's how we were
but i had other things happening in my
life when i was a kid
i had to tell nobody
and as time went batman i had to learn
how to adapt
i had to learn how to survive
you know but right now
i'm just existing i'm not living
i got a lot of [ __ ] inside me man and
there's a difference between existing
and living because when you're existing
you're just here
when you're living you enjoy life man
you enjoy life it's a big
difference man it's a big difference man
when i had it then i was
when i got older and realized who this
man really was man
you know he was too old for me even
tried to do anything
too
[Music]
and i wonder at that time why daddy
and his brothers didn't do nothing but i
had uncles
but they were too sick and cool they ran
the streets
you know what i'm saying they called my
old man rest in peace his nickname was
hot
his brother's name was johnny cool so
man
they were some cool cats
but they had their own thing going on
and it wasn't me
but uh yeah like i said man by the time
i realized who this cat was
he was part of my family so how has this
affected your later life
um
it's good to have to get close to kids
you know what i'm saying i have kids
tomorrow
but we so
departed that you know i get scared to
come around
you know i got some beautiful daughters
when i look at them like you know what
i'm saying i don't
know my songs
but when i look at him i don't i'm not
trying to go there
i don't even try to put myself in that
predicament
you know
i just i don't know because i i didn't
have the help
that i really needed mentally
i don't know what type of help you
probably need psychiatrists
i don't know i ain't had no help today
you know pills won't do it i don't know
i don't know i'm 54 years old i don't
know
i don't know and i'm not the same tell
you i don't know
i'm still gonna be trying to have a
some type of guidance somewhere man i
still
try to keep trying to keep an open mind
to get guided
because today i know it ain't over but i
don't know what
i don't know
i don't want ma'am i'm
i'm i'm tired of existing
i want to start living
you know and
and when you've been existing so many
years
it's normal now it's hard to
i got to recondition myself
and that's the action word now i got to
try to start
living man i i got so many years in
existence
it's gonna be hard to start living
because i don't know how to live
so you know
i'm just going to say
i wish they would listen to me when i
said it's the boogie man in my room
and they just thought i was joking
you know i'm saying cause you know mom
why
they didn't understand me but i was
saying
because like when i was a kid that's all
it was was the boogie man
you had to be scared of so they thought
i was just scared to go in the dark
be in the dark room in my room by myself
but then i realized i wasn't by myself
you know i don't want to drag along with
my story man i just had to tell y'all
what's kind of little happening with me
so you know mother father have you
talked about this before
have you talked about this with anyone
before no no you know what i'm saying
you know i might you know i i just
i don't talk about my issues with nobody
because
because they label you man
you can't out here they label you they
put a label on you
and then he don't tell him he's gonna
tell him because they want to be better
than you
they want to feel better than you so if
i tell you something about me
to help you feel better about yourself
to die on me
you know when i'm out there man i don't
have
whatever you do i ain't got nothing to
do with me
it ain't gonna help me it ain't gonna
hurt me
it definitely ain't gonna get me off
these streets
and it ain't gonna help the situation
that i'm going through because i go
through things too
so why should i put on take on what you
going through
cause i can't care you can't care what i
get
so how in the hell i'ma care what you
get so i don't care
what you do out there because it ain't
got nothing to do with me
nothing you know
i said man mother father sister brother
on tv
if you got a niece nephew kid someone
whatever daughter
if they say something they room they
talk about the boogie man
please go check
[Music]
might not be what they say but it's
something i do
i appreciate y'all only no disrespect
no harm to y'all thank you all right
thank you very much
you